مدينتي
وتحديدا من الموقع ذاته الذي استهدف فيه
عمران خان زعيم حزب انصاف
[موسيقى]
مسيرته الاحتجاجيه
عمران خان غابه شخصيه عن المسيره بسبب
اصابته لكنه حاضر على الشاشه
باكستان وهذه هي الديمقراطيه الشعب هو من
سيختار من يحكمه مستقبلا وهذا هو جوهر
مسيرتنا سنواصل نضالنا لتحقيق مطلبنا
الوحيد لم يغير حزب انصاف الهدف الرئيسيه
من هذه المسيره الاحتجاجيه بل زاد عليها
مطلب محاسبه من يتهممهم بمحاوله اغتيال
زعيمه
المشاركون في هذه المسيره الاحتجاجيه
سيحتاجون كما قالوا الى 10 ايام للوصول
الى العاصمه اسلام اباد يقطعون خلالها 200
كيلو متر ويامرون حشد مزيدا من الجماهير
للمشاركه في مسيرتهم واعطائي زخم اكبر
لمطالبهم
مستفيدين من الجغرافيا ينجح مؤيدو حزب
انصاف في اغلاق الطريق السريع الرابط بين
العاصمه اسلام اباد واقليمي البنجر
حيث يسيطر الحزب على الحكومتين المحليتين
هناك
الحكومه تسعى لتفعيل قوانين النظام
الفيدرالي لتوسيع سلطاتها وتتمسك بمواقفها
السياسيه
تحملنا كثيرا ممارسات حسب انصاف في
اقليمين وان كانت سلطات الممنوحه للاقاليم
بحسب مواد الدستور نساء استخدامها لاغلاق
الطرق فان لدى الحكومه الفيدراليه الكثيره
من الخيارات لحمايه الدوله فليس من
المعقول ان تتحكم قله في حركه الناس ونبقى
صامته وعلى الارض لا تراجعا من طرفي
الخلاف السياسي في باكستان عن اي من
المواقف
المعلني منها على الاقل
عبد الرحمن مطر الجزيره اقليم البنجاب